[Music]
this week on Q&A author and senior
advisor on baseball operations for the
Boston Red Sox bill James
mr. James talks about his book the man
from the Train the solving of a
century-old serial killer mystery
[Music]
bill James in your new book the man from
the Train your first sentence in the
preface is I have long been fascinated
by the notion that knowledge can be
created about the past tell us more
about that well the easiest example of
mentions in the book the easiest example
is dinosaurs for thousands of years
people had no idea that these great
beasts had ever existed now we have not
only created an information about them
but disseminated it so widely that every
four-year-old child has a collection of
little plastic dinosaurs much of what
academics do is create is sort out the
conflicts in what was said at the time
to create a clearer and more detailed
and more accurate picture of the past so
that we know things about the Romans
that the Romans didn't know we know
things about baseball in the 1960s that
the baseball players of the 1960s didn't
know when did you know that you wanted
to write this particular book the I
stumbled into it without making a
decision to do it I was supposed to be
working on a book with my wife which I'm
still working on about it's the cat
history of Kansas and the I saw a PBS
show about the murders in Villisca Iowa
and I thought I would put a couple of
hours into tracking down what facts I
could about it and a couple of hours
became a couple of weeks a couple of
weeks became a couple of months and it
eventually became seven years when was
the PBS documentary shown I would guess
2008 or 2009 but I'm not sure want to
ask you to read your opening page just
to set the scene on what we're about to
talk about all right it is a warm night
most often on a weekend there is a very
small town with a railroad track that
runs through the town or sometimes along
the edge of it you can't get more than a
few hundred feet away from the railroad
track and still be in the town
he is looking for a house with no dog he
would prefer a house on the edge of town
this isolated enough to provide a little
bit of cover a big two-story house would
be best with a family of five a barn
where he can hide out from sundown until
the middle of the night but in that era
before the automobiles came almost every
house had a barn even the houses in
Chicago and Philadelphia had barns he is
looking for a house with a woodpile in
the front yard and an axe sticking up
out of the woodpile
who is he he is a serial murderer who
lived more than a hundred years ago who
is as terrible a human being as has ever
walked the face of the earth do you know
his name I do know his name the and if
you absolutely insist I will give it to
you it but it is revealed at the in
toward the end of the book I don't
insist because I know that's one of the
things that it got to get to chapter 40
before you find out right but give us
some of a profile who this guy is and
and what what about Villisca Iowa where
is that Villisca Iowa is in the south
western corner of Iowa it's a town of
around 2,000 people on a night in June
hundred and some years ago all of the
lights were out the city was in us in
his dispute with the electric company
over the price of electricity and they'd
shut off the the streetlights on he on a
Monday morning in June the man did not
report to work man named Joe Moore and
on investigation it was found that there
was a locked house with all of the
windows covered and eight people inside
murdered with an axe this was
this was immediately linked within an
hour to a what we would now call a
serial murderer although the term wasn't
and used that serial murderer was
traveling the nation murdering families
and it was immediately recognized that
this was one of those it was another of
those cases have you been to there that
I have yes what's it like today the the
interior of the town has not done
terrifically a lot of the the highway
went half mile outside of town and the
Casey's general store moved to the edge
of town and that sort of thing the but
it's it's still a quiet peaceful little
place or it is once more
a quiet peaceful little place see that
murder has anybody ever been found or
prosecuted expecially back in those days
for the murder they say my know who
really was the at the time there were
two or three depending on how you count
them what I would consider bogus
prosecutions a man was arrested and
intimidated and beaten and put on trial
but they're not put on trial but what
and but indicted for the murders but the
indictment was dropped because there was
really no evidence and later a man known
as the little Minister Reverend Lynn
Kelly was Trice twice put on trial for
the crimes the IDI is my view and there
are still people who believe that that
Reverend Kelly committed the crime or I
regard that as a complete impossibility
how many crimes did you investigate for
this book well the we there were an
awful lot of crimes that it was one
point we thought might be related and
ultimately decided had no connection to
the story
and didn't including the book anywhere
there probably forty to fifty crimes
which are discussed in the book some of
those are relatively low probability of
being linked and some of them are
absolutely and unquestionably linked to
the in my view and don't mean to make
judgments for other people the some of
them seem to be unquestionably linked to
the Villisca murders where do you reside
I live in northeast Kansas it's actually
only about 180 miles from Villisca I
believe what town I live in Lawrence
Kansas the home of the Jayhawks I
probably have a Jayhawk necktie or
something on me right now I don't know
how long have you lived there we moved
back to Lawrence in 1991 and have lived
there well I spent two years in Boston
well my wife was getting a master's
degree from Boston University but
otherwise we've lived in Lawrence since
1991
now most people in this country you know
the name Bill James have no idea that
you're dealing in crime what would they
say you do for a living they would say I
was most people say I was a baseball
statistician and you can't use violence
to to prevent them from saying that so
you have to put up with the I write
about baseball and I've written about
baseball and analyze baseball almost all
of my life and that is what I'm best
known for are you still working for the
Boston Red so I still work for the
Boston Red Sox it's still very proud to
do something and so what do you do for
them the well I'm a consultant they I
try to keep up on everything that is
happening in the organization as much as
I can and I give my opinions I try to
create organized ways of thinking about
problems and try to encourage people
within the system to use those organized
ways of thinking about problems as much
as I can
your daughter helped you write this blog
he did and I want to quote from her in a
previous interview ok get you to expand
on it I think dad's writings shown the
most honestly when he was talking about
these small towns that he grew up in I
mean his parents were born right around
these years and they grew up in the
small town of his
is it may yada-yada-yada Kansas the kind
of place that the man from the train
attacked
I hope readers will take away a greater
sense of empathy for these tiny towns
that are just as interesting fascinating
and worthwhile as the largest city on
earth why is she saying that well the by
the way in working on this book I
reached the point of overconfidence in
what I knew that I absolutely believed
that if the man from the Train had ever
come to me out of Kansas I knew which
house he would have hit okay I could
narrow it down to two or three houses
which were in different towns but he has
such clear patterns that I know exactly
where he would have gone I grew up in a
small town in the 1950s and very much
like the places where the man from the
Train committed his murders there was no
police force and the no police force on
sight there was a County Sheriff
ten miles away the I understand not a
hundred years ago but 5060 years ago and
I have a lot of well I often feel that
the people who live in those towns are
not taken seriously that they're not
respected and that their view of life
it's not their political philosophy that
their view of life is not respected
can I read from your book sure what you
said because it's one of the more
interesting paragraphs of your book
you're free then we'll get real we don't
but no no then you can expand on this
and I warn our audience this stuff as
strong oh it's direct let's it that way
if you read about crime in a small town
you will encounter frequently to comment
that these people lived in the kind of
quiet place where nothing very
interesting ever happened this is a
despicable thing to say this is you
writing it is a form of bigotry directed
at the past and bigotry directed at
people who live in small towns and worse
yet it's ignorant
pardon my french you say but it's an
ignorant [ __ ] comment
and if you ever say anything like that
you are revealing yourself to be an
ignorant [ __ ] that is kind of how I
feel about it
the and I said pardon my french because
no use that language law in the book but
the I do feel that it's offensive to
talk about small towns as places where
nothing ever happens everything
meaningful that happens in your life or
my life happens just as often two people
live in small towns and people who lived
in small towns a hundred years ago as it
does to you and me the me the meaningful
things that happened to us in our lives
are that we fall in love we get married
we get divorced
we have children the children have
problems the we start a career we
succeed in our career or fail we go to
social events we go to entertainments
all of those things happen just as often
and just as profoundly in small towns a
hundred years ago
or in small towns today as they do to
people living in New York City or
Washington or Los Angeles today where
did you get this strong feeling about
small town well I grew up in a small
town the I live in a relative or New
York would consider a small town now
it's Lawrence Kansas its town of 80 to a
hundred thousand so it's not that small
but it's just it's not a feeling it's an
understanding it's it's Mithen happens
in a small town it's because you drive
through small towns and you don't see
anything happen but if you live there
you understand that people are living
their lives there and that's it's it's
it's just not true that that nothing
happens there the title the man from the
Train what's that come from the one of
the things that identifies the murder
we're talking about is that most many of
the crimes happen within a hundred yards
of the railroad track and one of the
things that helps us identify his crime
as opposed to somebody else's is that it
usually happens
at the intersection of two railroad
tracks the and it's at the intersection
of two railroad tracks presumably
because he knew he had to get out after
he committed his crime he had to get out
of town before dawn and he didn't want
to be stranded there waiting for a train
to come through that he can hop on so
being at the intersection of multiple
railroad tracks gave him the
opportunities to get out of town before
the crime was discovered what do you
want people to take from this book the
but I mean I know that well first of all
crimes are serious events I mean serious
people avoid talking about popular crime
were
celebrated criminal events because they
regard them as trashy and popular
cultural events but crimes are very
serious events they have a huge impact
on shaping how people live even if
you're not the victim of a crime and the
phenomenon of famous crimes has is a a
serious phenomenon that needs people to
stop blowing it off so that would be
number one number two is an
understanding of the time or a better
understanding of the time the what I was
trying to do was to create as much as I
could the time and the place were these
where these crimes occurred tried to get
people to understand that the world was
changing very rapidly at that moment as
it as it normally is but sometimes more
rapidly than others but it's not a
static world it's a rapidly changing
world which has a lot of things in
common with the way we live now and many
things different when did you first
begin to be interested in the numbers
the in the spring of 1961 I was captured
by a by a stack of baseball cards and
never really escaped so that's where it
comes from and how did you develop an
understanding of numbers the well
playing around with baseball statistics
actually I'm not really I'm not anything
of asportation would consider a
mathematician
very good at adding subtracting and
multiplying and dividing in my head but
that's just from from thousands of hours
of doing it with baseball statistics the
the but in terms of getting an
understanding of what could be done with
those when I was when I was College
Kansas University 1967 to 1971 I studied
economics and essentially what I have
done for my career is taking economic
methods and apply them to baseball that
essentially is all that I've ever done
other than you know cryin stuff but that
that is what I have done almost all of
my career is take economic models
economic theory is economists ways of
thinking about things and apply them to
baseball related question how how
important what you know obviously you do
research but how important was research
to this book's fairly obvious and how
did you go about it
well my daughter was in charge of the
research in it she became a co-author
because she in doing the research he
discovered things that were too large to
be ascribed to a researcher they you had
to say that that's this point you become
an author but essentially what we were
doing was uncover like scraping the dirt
away from like archaeology brushing the
dirt away from things that were a little
bit exposed but mostly hidden and you
know you brush the dirt away from them
and you find more and you
and you and you have a better clearer
picture what it is that's under the dirt
the I don't know if I answered your
question there the our our research
rachel's research was and you know i
didn't thought that i'd easy row
research did a lot of research myself
but the our research was essentially
based on old newspapers we we found day
of the crime news stories about all of
the crimes in the book and those are the
first of all many times the the day of
the crime description is the the most
reliable description because the more
often it gets repeated it becomes like a
game of telephone and the facts get lost
but but also those the description of
events which you start with provides
direction to other sources we've got
some video that was recorded and just
immediately last year at kansas city
star with your daughter and it's just
your daughter talking about looking for
this man the man from the train so we
can see the two of you together working
right i think that and this is not to
excuse him but i think he was acting out
some horrible trauma that happened to
him in childhood i think he was probably
viciously abused was never loved or
cared about and he was acting out that
horror throughout and i think that there
was a sexual motivation as well and as
horrible as that is to say i think that
became what his life was about that
became his purpose in life what is her
background she was born in in in 1986
grew up in that house where that video
was shot which is the house where we
lived and went to study that the
Holland's university and
in in Roanoke Roanoke Virginia not too
far from here
majored in creative writing was married
in maybe 2011 which would have been
three years after she graduated moved
back to Kansas in maybe two thousand
thirteen or fourteen and worked with me
on the book one of the chapters is
called the worst one ever and it goes
into some detail about this guy what he
did and why did you call it the worst
one ever and I think what is there a
tour see nine people killed at one time
and where was it you remember well it's
called the worst one ever because it's
the highest body count I mean in in
Villisca he killed eight people on one
night which is a horrific event but it
actually is we were quite astonished to
discover not the most people he'd killed
in one of that the but whereas the
crimes in Villisca are quite well known
today and millions of people know about
them and can tell you something about
them the murder of the Ackerman family
is so obscure that I actually joined the
the Historical Society of the county
where they crimes occurred what state in
Florida is that right I believe it near
Allentown paradigm for the and joined it
remotely obviously and could not find
anyone in the Historical Society of the
county where the crime occurred who had
ever heard of them they are totally and
absolutely forgotten except for the old
newspaper accounts the the murders of
the Ackerman family were difficult to
write about because not to speaking ill
of southerners in a way but the south at
that time had low levels of literacy
and because there were low levels of
literacy and a thin population there
were not many newspapers active in the
area there is no reason to believe that
any anyone from a newspaper organization
ever visited the scene of the crime or
ever interviewed a neighbor or a police
officer firsthand there's it's this
secondhand reports is all you all you
had to go on and you have to you know
we've reconstructed what happened as
best we could with as much confidence as
we could without trying to fool anyone
that we actually know what happened
because the facts are difficult page 288
I'll just start reading then you can
pick up with what you remember the akram
ins had probably left a kerosene lamp
burning in a back bedroom and likely the
first thing he did was take the shade
off the lamp and put it quietly on the
floor then start to examine the layout
of the house mrs. Ackerman however was
awake nursing her baby inside one of the
other rooms you say I am speculating
that she was awake
if you've ever had a two-day-old baby
you know why and also her body was found
outside the front door
what does this guy and I reminder folks
listening that you never was caught and
never was charged with anything and this
was in the early nineteen hundred's but
what did this guy do then in the
Ackerman's house well we assume that he
broke in through a rear window and you
can assume that he did that because he
always did in fact he loved windows so
much so that if there was a door there
and a window there and they were both
could be easily open he would go through
the window he just preferred to do that
he was a small man very athletic and it
was easy for him to scramble through
windows and he did so he entered we can
assume that he entered the house near
midnight because he always entered the
house near midnight the and there at and
there are two reasons to think that he
entered at the rear of the house
one is that he always did and the other
is that some of the victims three of
them I believe in County including the
two day old baby were found outside the
front door as if they had been chased in
that direction they were chased toward
the front of the house and hit with an
axe just after they exited the front of
the house yeah I kept asking why didn't
any of these folks get away from this
guy right and all the incidences they
seem to all died right and that is one
of the most remarkable things about the
crime about the series of crimes is that
there were a remarkably low number of
people who lived through the event in
any way shape or form and that's because
it's it's mostly because he was quite
exceptionally good at what he did I mean
it was not a dumb person because he was
very skilled at what he was trying to
accomplish and it must it must be that
he attacked very quickly you say there
were 33 things that you could tag to
this man right and I've got it marked
here how did you find the 33 and you
list every one of them well we started
with a list of five and added added the
sixth and the seventh and eight the not
33 things totally different but there
are there are 33 elements of the crime
for example he very often takes a the in
that era houses many houses did not have
electricity they had electricity in
these small towns where he's attacking
it's not it's not it's limited
electricity not on all the time the so
people would leave a lamp burning
through the night so that there would be
a lamp they would have a starting place
in the morning the he would take the
lamp take the chimney off the lamp or
shade off the lamp and put it very
quietly on the floor and then he would
turn the lamp down very very very low so
it was just a flicker I think he did
that in part because of course he needed
to see his way around the house but also
it excited him that gastly thin light
was part of the thrill for him I believe
that's speculation
no one convinced people I know but that
getting into his head as much as one can
do without going completely crazy the I
think it was I think that was part of
the thing for him so that's one thing
that identifies the man I a train that a
crime that is linked to the man from the
train as opposed to a similar crime
which doesn't turn out to be linked
another of course is proximity to the
railroads the the intersection of
multiple railroads another is the use of
an axe the it's always the blunt side of
the axe it always always well I
shouldn't say always very often when he
kills five people one person who is most
likely to be the woman of the house is
struck with the sharp side of the axe
also however there is no crime in the
group which in which most of the murders
were not committed with the blunt side
of the axe it's always the blunt side of
the axe the and that so that's that's a
signature element we have no reason to
believe that he ever killed anyone in
daylight although you know if he you
know this is a vicious human being and
if he if he took a note to kill someone
in daylight he probably would have but
that we have no reason to believe that
he killed anyone in daylight
it's always near midnight it's not 4:00
a.m. it's not 3:00 a.m. it's than an
hour of midnight the oh I've got it now
I've got tell you some of the others
that he paid special attention to the
body of the prepubescent female staging
or posing of the preview
female while other victims are simply
left as they were when they were killed
and often I think I read in these
accounts that these child this young
ladies would be not about around 9 years
old yes that a 9 to 12 year old girl is
his target victim I mean a basically is
killing the not that he enjoys killing
people I mean he just loves killing
people but his target victim is a 9 to
12 year old girl
the another signature element is that he
covers the heads of the victim with the
blanket before he hits them over the
head and he does that so the blood
doesn't spray back on him the the but so
if you see people we have a report of a
crime shows the the victims heads being
covered with cloth before they are
murdered that's a sign that it's him if
there's a young girl and her clothing
has been removed and she's lying with
her limbs askew that definitely is him
and we can there are grosser aspects to
that which will maybe don't need to talk
about the and the another thing that we
know it's him is he uses a law it uses
cloth to block all the windows he will
take blankets or or robes or whatever
and cover all of the windows and that's
presumably done after the crimes are
committed so that he can move around the
house after and the darkness without
being spotted by people walking on the
sidewalk you say that he never stole
anything never stole well the first
crime first crime he stole some crowd
but he was no he never stole anything
many many of the crimes it is reported
that there is money and jewelry left in
in in plain view after the crime is
committed how often did he set fire to
the house
up until 1908 he almost always set fire
to the house after 1908 up until 1900
he's murdering families in in houses
near small towns but not actually in
small towns beginning in nineteen
transition but 1908 to 1910 he begins
the he moves into small towns at at that
point he can't set fire to the house
because if he set fire to the house at
four o'clock in the morning people will
come running and they'll be aware that
something is terribly wrong before you
have any chance to escape say he
committed the crimes almost always in
warm weather always always in warm
weather this there's one crime that
could be related which is committed and
terrible cold weather and the first
crime the first crime that he committed
which is in 1898 was in cold weather and
I suspect that that's relevant because
Isis yeah after that he had to walk six
or seven miles in the middle of the
night in cold weather in order to avoid
detection and in order to get out of the
way and I suspect that that was such a
after this is generally true of serial
murderers that that their first crime is
an explosion and is poorly planned or
not planned at all it's just an
explosion of anger or lust or a
combination thereof the after or that
there is normally a cooling-off period
and during the cooling off period the
person contemplates what they need to do
to get by with this in the future and I
feel relatively certain that in that
period of study and contemplation it's
the study and contemplation are good
words and there's nothing good about
this but the in that period that he
decided that he didn't want to do this
in cold weather anymore because other
than that one peculiar crime in Nova
Scotia
in February which is about as cold as
you can get other than that no no crimes
in cold weather what was his profession
the going back to the first crime at the
time of the first crime people would say
that he had that he was trained in
veterinary veterinary medicine that
doesn't mean what it means now in but he
had some skills working with animals he
had been a sailor and but his main
profession throughout the period of time
which is committing the crimes is he was
what we would now call a lumberjack
although the word lumberjack was not
used in exactly the same way than it is
now but he was what we would call a
lumberjack and we know that that's true
because almost all of the crimes up till
1910 occur in city and some of them
after 1910 occur in towns where the
chief industry is logging I want to talk
to you about a lot of the other things
that you get involved in ok siccola your
philosophy of life by the way does
anybody ever say to you bill where do
you spend all this time with this kind
of gruesome stuff well though people
that know me know that I'm a creep so
they're not just kidding they yes people
said it people do look askance at the at
the time that I spend on in looking into
old murders the and it is regarded as
all and somewhat off-putting by many
people I know but don't like it do - it
is newspapers that were my basic
education I mean I okay I went to grade
school I went to high school at college
but from the time I I was five years old
until I was until I told newspapers died
I was an avid reader of newspapers and
newspapers
shaped my view of the world I grew up in
a small town quite a ways from from
industry from forestry
there were our lives were as rich and
and complicated as the lives of people
of big cities but I remember when I was
about 11 years old asking my sister what
an antique store was we didn't have
antique stores you know there were a lot
of things that you don't had that didn't
have in small towns in the those times I
used newspapers to figure out the world
more or less I think people in my
generation did and if you look at
newspapers there's sports and there's
crime stories and there's comics and
Dear Abby and and one page of political
commentary and and that that formed by
those things form my view of the world
the car I've read crime stories and read
crime books since I was seven years old
now I have to admit following you in
baseball is one thing seeing that you're
interested in crime is another but this
is I have to say in doing research on
your visit here this is the biggest
surprise I had this is from Ben McGrath
and the New Yorker in 2003 right he
writes a profile on you he says he turns
on c-span which he watches more than any
other channel and finds another
politician lying thus presenting the
kind of puzzle that he has been trying
to solve all his life quote this is you
you have to try to reconstruct the
organization of your thoughts so that it
reaches to the point of defending the
absurd proposition that they are
defending and then try to reconstruct
the organization of your own thought so
that you have a place to put the true
fact which is consistent with your
underlying belief give us more well
first of all I have no memory of having
said that and and
I know people don't believe this but I
don't read anything written about me
even though great admiration for Ben
McGrath but I never read that piece the
what it touches on by central philosophy
of life which is this well I can explain
this at about 20 seconds the world is
much more complicated than the human
mind and for that reason and yet we are
desperate to understand the world we are
committed from the moment of birth to a
struggle to understand the world which
we can never win because that is true we
make up understandings of the world
which we call religion or political
philosophy or expertise the and we we
believe these things are true and as
consequence of that we all believed
thousands of utterly nonsensical
statements to be true then says that
their politicians are lying but I don't
know that they're lying white
politicians say things that are not
objectively true with great frequency
but it's not clear to me that they do
not in general believe these things to
be true they are merely operating out of
a paradigm of understanding which has
wandered away from the facts which can
be established did that make any sense
at all of this let it lie let me ask you
that why do you watch this and do you
still watch this that was 2003 t you're
still watching and what do you see from
Lawrence Kansas that we don't see living
in this place well the reason I am as he
spend junky it relates to what just
happened which is I asked for feedback
on something and you refused to give it
the but that is that is the reason that
that I am a c-span junkie is your
discipline
and your commitment to to staying as
close to the facts as without your own
interpretation your own overlaying of it
as you possibly can do I take a lot of
crap from my liberal friends because I
watch Fox News and but I also watch CNN
and and PBS and and it's not that I I'm
old tried to figure out the world as
everybody is but I'm always trying to
create organized ways of thinking about
the world and c-span is more useful for
that than sources which think they have
the world figured out if that makes
sense you tweet and I ask you a second
time why you tweet but I mean here's one
of your tweets and in December how many
of us are old enough to remember when
Meet the Press and Face the Nation would
spend the whole hour interviewing a news
maker rather than 10 minutes with a news
maker and 50 minutes of talking heads
let me ask you though in the context
that this the the ten minutes of the
news maker 50 minutes of talking is
works it's successful it is commercially
successful why do you think that is more
successful than the old way the well
it's part of a system that has developed
and as a part of we headed in that
direction
when people probably in the LG LBJ
administration but maybe it was FDR
before my time I don't know we all tend
to think that things started when we
became aware of them but when the
politicians started showing up for the
morning news shows with a list of
talking points and pushing the direction
and push and then then it became
inevitable that the
that the news people would would try to
get away from the talking points that
they would try to escape the talking
points the the talking head format
developed as an as a a way to I'm going
to come at this from a different angle
what I was saying before my basic
philosophy of life is that everybody has
to have a system of understanding
everything and that's unfortunate
because all of the systems of
understanding everything are just
[ __ ] none of them work none of them
and none of them have any any real no
one understands the world no one has the
capacity to understand the world and all
of the carefully articulated systems to
place everything our inherently false
but everyone has one almost everyone is
either a conservative or a liberal or a
libertarian or a a lunatic of some other
stripe so the in a competitive news
environment the thing to do is to find
the the underserved group of partisans
and find a way to appeal to them here's
a tiny little bit of your philosophy
this is 17 seconds you made a speech in
November of 2016 one of the great
problems with the with human race is
that greed has no natural limit and if
greed had a natural limit we would all
that then it would we would all work
through our problems a lot quicker but
it doesn't boy doesn't have great why
doesn't agree to have a natural in it
well the
we organized religion and philosophy and
politics our efforts to form
philosophies which place limits on the
on the catastrophic consequences of
greedy behavior but as to why I believe
that greed has no natural limit it has
to do with with sixty years of reading
crime books criminals are simply people
who put more value on their two minutes
of pleasure than they do on your life
the man from the Train put more value on
his hour of satisfaction than he did on
the lives of the hundred people or so
that he killed his greed had no limit
and I simply most of us limit our greed
most of us limit our greed by philosophy
or religion but it has no inherent and
natural limit if philosophy and religion
are taken away as a baseball aficionado
and observer and advisor and all that
for the Boston Red Sox and you look at
the baseball business and I can pick any
of these businesses but what do you
think will happen with is the incredible
amount of money that's being paid for
somebody to throw a baseball or hit a
baseball and the agents and the team
owners and all that and the cost of the
rights for television as they keep going
up where does that all go and is there
any greed in that mix no it's
Brian I know you try not to express
opinions but you know that there's greed
in that mix the yes it's tremendous
amount of greed in that Nick so where it
will go in the in the big picture and in
the long term is that eventually a
competitive structure will evolve which
which results in a more reasoned
reasonable distribution of of the assets
of games eventually there will be either
either the major sports will expand
where they have 200 teams each or there
will be competitive leagues established
so that there are 200 teams in each
sport in the United States and once that
happens the money that gets concentrated
into relatively few hands will blow
across the horizon more however is that
going to happen in the next five years
probably not but it it will happen at
some point
in the next two lifetimes let's say
another 38 seconds of your philosophy
and a speech you gave at Longwood
University back in 2015
certainty is the immediate cause of the
most awful and justices in the world
there has been a news story within the
last week or so to the effect that the
FBI forensic forensics experts on hair
comparison analysis had been lying to
help convict people on terrible crimes
for the last 30 years FBI agents have
testified improperly in thousands of
cases over a long period of time almost
always on behalf of the prosecution and
now as a society we're going to have to
deal with the fallout from that why did
you want to say that in that speech the
it's again
the core of my belief system that that
certainty that that these philosophies
we create out of nothing these false
explanations of all phenomena in the
world
are the core of our being that was the
news story which was in the news at that
time and and so I picked that up and
used it the to tie into my the general
point that I was making however also I
was working on this book at that time
right that at the time I gave that
speech I was working on the book one of
the things that happens that happened in
these towns where the management trained
committed his crimes is that in at least
two cases and and well what would always
happen is that is that people would
decide based on no evidence at all that
they knew who committed the crime the
but in at least two cases and possibly
three black men were murdered by lynch
mobs because they were certain that this
person had to have committed the crime
if you go back and you look at what was
their reason for believing that it it
was nothing but the certainty that they
were that they knew who committed the
crime led to injustice as it always does
and I was terribly bothered by the case
of Ryan Ferguson it was a young man in
Missouri who spent several years in
prison for a crime that we should have
been obvious to anybody who looked at it
for 20 minutes that he couldn't possibly
have committed the but the the the
prosecutors were certain that they knew
what happened and their certainty that
they knew what happened led to injustice
if you look at any crime story and you
walk backward on it and say where did
this crime story begin the answer is
that it always begins in a fantasy well
basically all crimes began in a fantasy
but if you look at a case of injustice
and you walk backward on it and say
where did this injustice originate it
originates in the certainty that we know
what happened
when in reality we did not know what
happened I found this to be a Bill James
ISM I'm not sure it is but at the very
end of the book and in the
acknowledgments I want to ask you why
you wrote this sentence this way I would
like to thank some very nice lady at the
Kansas Historical Society who may have
been Susan Forbes Sarek kekel s'en or
Sarah Garden I'm sorry I have lost the
slip of paper that had your name on it
the yes well I did some research at the
at the Kansas Historical Society and I
wrote down the name of the of the very
nice lady who helped me but I lost the
name and rather than pretending I knew
it was and thanking the wrong person I
just thank them all why didn't you call
him up and ask him the it had been two
three years later and I don't think they
would have would have remembered me also
I'm lazy lazy in chapter 40 was written
by your daughter is that the chapter
about Clementine run about no this is
the chapter about the first crime and
who committed it and it starts out by I
found the first crime on cold January
night I was not yet an author of this
book just a researches she wrote a great
bit a great deal of that chapter yes she
wrote that phrase the reason I ask that
is as anybody else ever found someone
they thought was the man from the Train
I mean you name the person you tell us
where he died all that kind of stuff and
I'm not going to give it away here but
but were you the first people to
discover this we were the first person
to people to tie him to the crime
the
there were two people in Villisca who
were tied to the Villisca crimes there
were people who were murdered for the
belief that they committed an isolated
crime but I don't think and there have
been if I could be arrogant for a moment
there had been there have been there
have been people claiming that a person
responsible for the series of crimes was
a or B or C but you can't really take
them seriously because they're not
serious researchers and they don't do
the work to establish that they know
what they're talking about we're the
first kind of serious people to nominate
somebody another tweet okay guys relax
our president is not crazy he just has a
debilitating lack of self-awareness and
has spent 60 years compensating for that
by trying to appear to be Superman okay
when you phrase it that way it sounds
crazy but he's no crazier than Napoleon
or Caesar or da the
like all good liberals I have a rather
intense dislike of our president however
I have a great respect for democracy I
didn't vote for him but he was elected
he had an idea of he he had a set of
things that he wanted to work on he had
a set of ideas that he put in front of
the American people those ideas won the
election that fact is entitled to
respect and I'm always trying in my own
way to lower the temperature a little
bit and get people to work back toward
the facts rather than well you know as
well as I do the media has been running
around for the last couple of weeks
saying today the president is crazy
the president is crazy it doesn't help
our democracy to work well to be doing
that you say in a 1914 New Republic
interview in politics on the other hand
we've made no progress at all people who
are perceived as learned experts go on
television and say stupid stuff that's
not the word you use and nobody says
quote boy that's really stupid don't you
find that to be true yes I mean that
that the explanations that politicians
give for the phenomena that are
happening not politicians but the
Talking Heads the explanations they give
for phenomenon are patently untrue in
case after case after case left and
right the I hate to pick on David Brooks
because he's a good one right he's not a
bad one but I remember in the it's the
example that always stuck with me in the
2008 Democratic campaign David Brooks
promised us that Hillary would beat
Barack Obama because the a Democratic
contest always comes down to someone
who's favored by the
by the educated public and what and
someone who is favored by the but by the
by the college grad the democratic
college graduates and someone who's
favored by the Democratic working class
and the person favored by the working
class always wins it's such an stupid
analysis that it's it's difficult to
believe that anyone ever said that I
mean if in baseball you offered a
comparable analysis of why why one team
would win the World Series you'd be
laughed off the stage I mean it is true
that baseball analysis in the 1960's and
1970's relied on generalizations of that
nature
in which you take that the problem with
the generalization of that nature is
that you take you take seven or eight
contests and draw a generalization about
how they came out and then say that that
generalization has to hold a null Fault
in all future contests it's such obvious
ly flawed logic that it's difficult to
believe anyone would would say such
things I find this to be generally true
of talking-head analysis and this gets
back to why I want to go back to Face
the Nation talking to interviewing the
the newsmaker rather than interviewing
another journalist but but the I find
the liberal analysis of the facts and
and the conservative analysis the facts
to be filled with such obviously silly
generalizations that mecan't it's it's I
can't comprehend why people can't see
through thought about this for years why
are people not able to see through silly
generalizations of that nature but we
hear them every day
our guest has been Bill James who lives
in Lawrence Kansas works for the Boston
Red Sox is an expert on crime solving
has a book out called the man from the
Train and has a Twitter account thank
you very much for joining us thank you
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
[Music]